[Musique]
de l'établi à l'entrée bienvenue dans la
maison de famille paris on ne pense tout
en obtenant ses décors là mais ça fait
toujours énormément plaisir
je suis content que mon que serait
entrée dans la maison des paris
au musée pointe à callière représente
tous les décors originaux qui sont
demeurés intacts comme le family la
chambre à coucher
c'est réconfortant c'est qu'on fantasme
ça suce point de bouffe habiter un
kindle mais j'adorais les fans avec
savez sans doute c'est toujours un
plaisir ça se passe avec ça pourrait
être drôle à chaque fois bien mais tous
étaient un outil excessive 59 épisodes
et trois émissions spéciales ont été
enregistrés dans ces décors l'émission
ralliait parfois fou et 4 millions de
téléspectateurs
autant de scènes autant d'expressions
qui nous ont marqués tu t'es pâté
chinois les nations pâté chinois dans le
frigo
ceci est un gros travail de sape le
travail le travail des accessoiristes de
travail des des costumes le frey les
décors c'est tout seul c'est ça qui a
fait à petite ville c'est pas juste les
textes les comédiens hissel certainement
contribué à donner un niveau un temps
moi j'ai capoté quand j'ai vu ça en plus
des membres de la famille plus de 120
personnages se sont invités chez les
paris quand nos tournées que céline dion
personnes savaient que céline dion était
cachée dans d'abord d'en publier qui
n'ont jamais su dans le bus on a envoyé
le public de gto comédiens on va faire
une autre prison j'ai joué mes yeux je
sais faire je vous dis pas qu'il va
sortir sa garde-robe ouvre toi
mais tout cela semble adorer mais marc
labrèche qui apparaît dans sa phase ni
quand il traiterait les états du québec
ouvre la porte
et
[Applaudissements]
l'exposition renferme également des
croquis l'industrie des maquettes et
plus de 200 pour steam ce que l'on se
reconnaît l'intimé personne dit que
c'est toujours ces soldes jamais ici
julie jasmin boudreau radio canada
montréal
[Musique]